Hier wohnte -
- deportiert.
- ermordert.
They're made out of brass and
they they always start off with:
'Hier wohnte'
'Hier lebte'
or sometimes 'hier arbeitete'
'here worked' and then,
the name of the person, their year of birth.
And after that as much information as is known
about their eventual fate.
Sometimes there is a notation
that the person committed suicide
and they're kind of quite affecting
the way it's phrased sometimes it's sort of:
'Selbstmord', but I read one that said:
'Fled into death.'
It's an another way to learn history.
It's an open book and you're reading:
They killed 6 million Jews.
That's abstract.
But when the students just around the corner,
in their neighbourhood,
they can imagine and that idea they can read:
'Paul, he was so old as me.'
When he was deported.
I think that's another way to learn history.
In the old part of Cologne, the South part,
old women came and said to me:
Well, it's pretty good what you're doing here
But here in our area, never lived gypsy people
and she really don't know.
And it was ther same with the Jewish population.
They were totally, well, neighbours
And that was at least idea to bring back some names in front of the houses where it started
where other people were at their home
and then were called out
and were deported.
And bring back the names, that was -
Then I had a contact to the rabbi of Cologne
and he told me, I don't know where it is in the Talmud.
But a man is forgotten when his name is forgotten.
That was idea to bring back the names.
Alfred Levy, Jahrgang 1881. Deportiert 1940 Gürs. 1942 - Ermordet.
They were cousins.
One of my great grandmother.
Older members of my family.
They were old men at the time,
who lived in a small town
on the Southern German Weinstraße,
and they were very, very much loved
members of the community
and very sadly missed when they were deported.
And there are still a handful of people alive today
who were children in the 1930s
who have very, very fond memories of these two old men.
...von Alfred Levy and seinem Bruder Gustav.
erzählte die heute 84-Jährige.
Oft machte sie einen Abstecher zur Wohnung der Levys,
Alfred, the younger brother by 10 years,
was very well known in Klingenmünster, their hometown.
He worked as a travelling salesman of
farming and domestic equipment.
and also ran a shop.
The brothers lived together.
They had a housekeeper
until it was forbidden by law
for Gentiles to work for Jewish families.
And then she had to stop looking after them.
He was very, very popular.
The children absolutely loved him.
He allowed them to run riot in their house,
play games with them,
fed them sweets and biscuits,
allowed them to ride on his horse.
They were much more innocent times.
Tripping the memory, or tripping the thoughts.
Sometimes people asked me:
'You can make it in the Fabrik, by machine.'
But then I say:
'Auschwitz was a fabric - for death.'
So, every stone is made by hand, individually.
I think it's very important.
When I started, for me as an artist,
it was conceptual art.
In the way, I'd never had the idea to realise.
But what then a priest in Cologne,
a Protestant priest, who told me:
'Well Gunter, you will never reach the million,
but you can start small.'
Well now, it's I think, next year to go to:
100,000 stones. In 29 countries in Europe.
Maybe 30 countries.
And that's idea:
to bring the stones to every country in Europe
where the Deutsche Wehrmacht, the SS, the Gestapo
deported people, killed people and with terror.
That there as a symbol, be these stones.
And that will go on and on.
And for this I made a foundation,
that it can go on, because well I'm born in '47, so.
But I think it will. It is for the future.
And especially young people are really, very interested.
How could this happened in the so called
Land der Dichter und Denker. Germany.
And at least, never have it happen again.
Hier wohnte -
Deportiert.
Ermordert.